how did pete davidson come about to be
like directing it and all this how this
relationship developed so pete and i
have been friends for a long time you
know uh pete had saw me
pete saw me
uh
in new york city when he was like 16
and i was you know i i think i was
opening for bill burke caroline's and i
just see this lanky kid and you know and
he was just and then i saw him again at
stand-up new york and he was like hey
man i love the podcast i think it was
really nice and then we had the same
manager at one point when we were
working the stand and we just were
friends and i put him on the versi
effect when he was 18 before everything
and we just stayed cool but like you
know he was we were talking and he's
like dude he's like i'd love to you know
direct your special
and uh then he told me one time he's
like dude you know like this is the best
[ __ ] you've done and he was like you
know and he came out on stage the night
of the taping and he goes i saw paul at
16 and i saw him perform in the city and
he became one of my favorite comics and
he wanted to be a part of it you know
pete asked me you know we were hanging
out he's like i'd love to be a part of
it i love to put my name behind it and
and so you know pete is one of the best
most misunderstood kids i've said that
millions of times he's the [ __ ] best
he's he's actually down to earth and the
sweetest he's so [ __ ] cool and down
to earth like people would not believe
how [ __ ] chill he is and cool and um
yeah man he's one of my best friends
he's one he's like a little brother to
me so um but yeah he he wanted to be a
part of it because of you know as he was
coming up he saw me and he's like oh i
want to do that that was pretty cool wow
and then like you said reference that
you were opening for bill burr when into
your career
you started in 2000
like how long into your career did you
start opening up for bill
burr so
yeah and how did that happen i i i did a
spot i
it was thanksgiving
weekend
in 2005 and bobby kelly came in for the
wednesday thanksgiving eve and then bill
came in on friday saturday and he was
just like dude you you know that was so
i he's like were you the other guy on
the show and he goes i was downstairs i
heard it you killed i'm gonna watch you
so then he referred me to a room
and i did well there he heard i did well
at the room he referred me to he goes
hey how about next time i do that room
you work with me so then like around 07
we became we became friends and then i
remember one day in 2008 he goes hey i'm
going to watch dc and probably you want
to open and i was like yeah and we just
kind of we just kind of been you know
it's like my family now so you know um
opening for him and and you know having
him believe in me you know it was pretty
cool because i would just be like home
chilling and somebody would go hey dude
burr just called you a beast on his
podcast and i it meant a lot because i
knew bill doesn't put that out there and
i know bill's not somebody to ever give
one thing he always says is like you
never give false hope
so i know bill would never [ __ ] go on
his podcast to his fans and say that you
know say the nice things like that paul
versus the beast it meant a lot because
i knew
it's funny i'll actually see his name
right there on the wall yeah right there
yeah i'm pretty i'm pretty sure but so
uh
yeah i think that having somebody like
that say that is also adds to your
confidence because you're dealing with
one of the best and they see what you're
doing and they see your progression and
they start saying things they think
you're gonna do and it's completely
[ __ ] humbling and it's like it gets
you through
what are some of the biggest lessons
you've learned from like working with
him so closely
[Music]
you know i i don't know
i don't know if it would be lessons of
of stand up because we are just
different people you know like his his
approach is obvious like we're just
different but i think just kind of doing
something where it's like um
you're not leaving are you
oh are you
no no we've got two
we've got oh yeah i'll say goodbye well
yeah when i'm done hang out you got two
and a half minutes no no it's all right
we go longer oh word oh can you open can
you move pull that door back uh the
other way yeah there's a light on it can
you push it all the way back
yeah yeah appreciate it yeah
um
you know you go longer are you sure yeah
oh we we made it we ran the light all
right um
yeah i don't know like you know bill has
his way i have my way but i think just
being
i think just being honest you know i
think just being [ __ ] honest like
just like
you know
one you know
one thing i learned i remember one time
i told a joke and there was like an
exaggerated part of the joke
and he goes all right now tell me what
really happened right so it was like
yeah that's exaggerated but what's the
what how did it really happen and then
you say how really happy he's like see
that's funny or as funny
so you don't have to do the so that was
one thing that i remember when i was
younger you know i can't remember the
joke exactly it was a strip club joke it
was a strip club joke i was in a strip
club
and i'm like such a nice guy so i
remember like it like to like went like
that [ __ ] like i'm nice and parts where
i shouldn't be
so i'm in a strip club and this chick is
just sitting there like you're [ __ ]
man when was this dude
i was i was
where was i
i was in a strip club i was probably
like 18 19 years old whatever and this
chick is just standing there and her
[ __ ]
tits are out and i just was like hey do
you have a family
and she goes she goes yeah i have a i
have a son
and i remember being like what are you
doing here and she goes are you a cop
and
but but my my version of it was like
something exaggerated right
no that's funny just her saying are you
a cop but i tried to make it some
different thing yeah you know like made
it more about her kid and her son and
like going into the you know she's got
pictures of her kids in the [ __ ] lap
dance room and bill was like you don't
need to i remember there was a long time
ago i was like oh yeah so i think like
just doing [ __ ] like that you know but i
was i was really younger at the time
when i would do that like it's weird
like you say jokes to somebody like that
and you're like now you're like oh [ __ ]
i said that but i was young of course
you know so so uh yeah but no just like
we're so similar as how we like treat
people man treat everybody with respect
and and just be cool we're you know just
kind of you know easy going get along
guys that like sports we have a good
time talking so it was kind of like
similar type of [ __ ] like that so it
just worked it just worked yeah and i
love seeing and what we're all about
here at hop breath is like comics
helping comics and being like a positive
and supportive community for comedians
to develop
uh because coming up when i came up i
mean i
there it was i mean i came up in the
hood rooms of atlanta like white people
didn't mess with me like i went where
there was stage time too i came up in
black rooms in new york it was the best
yeah because black black people are
honest like when you perform for black
people you got to be authentic and
honest and they'll laugh but white
people you know sometimes you can hide
behind cleverness but when you perform
in front of black people they're like
well what's what's the real deal here
yeah you know and that really helps you
early on in that
just being a white boy joel that's
that's how i came up in this game yeah
yeah that's cool right no i respect that
i appreciate that because i i did that
too do you ever get booed any like no
rough bombs like that um thanks for
watching hop breath the verse if you
enjoyed this clip subscribe to see our
400 plus comedy interviews and click
this video up here to hear paul versus
worst bomb story ever